- Hello, my name is Natasha.
I am a reporter for
Russian television
here to cover American culture.
Today, I talk to classic
American persons.
(light music)
Hello, I am here with
classic American Comedian
Maria Bamford.
If apocalypse happen,
how will you help?
- I know I'm the first one
who will eat all the chocolate
if we're in a rubber raft.
I cannot be trusted.
I wanna say I can be a meat
shield thrown in front of
a shark or what have you.
- That is very selfless.
- Well, no, I just
think I'm realistic
of what I'm capable of.
- And also, who wants to be
around once apocalypse happen?
- That's what I said.
- Americans love paying a
lot of money for cheap things
like eggs and pizza, how do
you throw your money away?
- I spent $7 on a coffee today--
- Yeah and that's truly crazy
because it's beans and water.
- You get to a
certain point where--
- It's like dirty beans.
It's black beans and water.
Do Americans like food trucks?
- San Francisco likes
food trucks a lot.
- See, I am confused by food
trucks because I thought
if there is a man in
a van giving out food,
you don't go inside.
- They're not
offering lollipops.
- Okay, but if they are offering
lollipops, that's the sign
it's no good.
But if it's a wet hot dog
or something, that's okay.
- And especially if it's
$20 you know that it's good.
- The more expensive,
the better.
the less the predator.
- Yes.
- You have traveled all across
the US performing stand-up.
What are you running from?
- Definitely from a
fear that I don't exist.
You've got to keep traveling
to see that people still know
that you are alive
and then merch, merch.
The exchange of merch
with other comics.
- It's like a barter system.
- Yeah, as a barter system.
- In my apartment, I have
seven DVDs that I stack up one
on top of another just
to show I have wealth.
- What music are they?
- Pornographic, I think.
- Oh, nice!
- So, there is music but
I would say people are
maybe off key.
What about festivals
do you love?
- It's a good value for money.
You come in, you pay
one price, you can see
so many different acts at once.
- Festivals is like the
Wal-Mart of entertainment.
- I like to think that people
just go because everyone else
is going.
- It's like that famous
phrase, if your friend jump off
a bridge, don't
embarrass yourself,
jump off that bridge first.
- Yeah, that's it,
that's the saying.
- And you have a
Golden Gate Bridge here
perfect for jumping.
You heard it here first,
they're going to jump off
the Golden Gate Bridge.
(laughing)
- Your show Joel
Joy (bleeping) Club.
Joel Joy (bleeping) Club is a
celebration of Asian talent.
- Yes.
- Government okay with
you starting race war?
- I don't think they love
it but they've accepted it.
- Do you worry that you put
them all together in one room?
- No, I didn't actually
think that it would be a trap
until just now.
- Thank you so much,
thank you so much, Joel.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Can we get him a napkin
because I might have
cold sore or something.
(upbeat music)